[Applause]
[Music]
tell
fight
[Music]
h
n
[Music]
you're not getting
way die in silence
[Music]
KO
you
win
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description want to be featured in ooto
TV send in your Clips by following these
steps before you submit your Clips make
sure the quality of the video is clear
put your IGN as a file name for your
video limit submissions to three to five
Clips a week per category don't spam
submissions and don't send folders with
your Clips on it avoid F length matches
or just cut the clip you want on the
desired play Until the End of the round
next send your Clips via Dropbox in the
correct category you can always find it
on the description of every ooto TV
series Once you upload your video file
if it prompts you to give your name just
put in your
[Music]
IGM also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay
[Music]
match please understand that it may take
some time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
[Music]
oh